here's something weird a conversation
about game balance and league of legends
actually changed that games eSports
scene forever in 2016 pro players and
team owners were mad that Riot Games
kept changing their game at the worst
possible time and in their attempt to
pressure Riot to rethink the way they
patch their game around Pro play they
ended up changing the business model of
League eSports forever and the craziest
part about that is that we are
responsible for it sort of mm-hmm
kind of No No maybe he'll know a little
No
[Music]
20:16 was a frustrating time for League
Pro players and team owners it's not the
scene with stagnating far from it
it was actually growing faster than ever
but there weren't a lot of people
outside of riot who were seeing the
benefits of that growth the league at
that point was still a pretty risky
venture sure it was one of the biggest
eSports in the world but it was a pretty
uncertain proposition for a non endemic
investor looking to get into the space
teams were still able to be relegated
and if you happen to put together a team
that wasn't saved good enough for the
current meta your investment went down
the drain at the end of the season now
the Nexus it's the 3:04 echo fox to hold
on to their spot in 2017 then we bid
farewell to energy esports in the LCS
and you didn't even have to put together
a terrible team to be at risk see
winning is popularity and if you had a
team that was good enough to stave off
relegation but not good enough to win
most of their games you weren't gonna
build up the kind of fan base that
sponsors are looking for naturally it
was a hot topic going into the 2016 na
LCS summer finals so in an interview
with Team solomid owner Andy Reginald in
X Pro Stara asked him about it like
what's your personal opinion on these
types of last-minute changes wait wait
wait wait can we get a zoom in on that
Mike flag that's right
skaara was asking that question for the
score esports which if I'm being
intellectually honest means nothing
doesn't matter and has nothing to do
with the rest of this story but if I'm
being petty which I will be it means
that that seemingly innocuous question
is responsible for the shitstorm that
you're gonna hear about in the rest of
this video back to the interview well I
mean if you look at it from a fan
perspective right they have a lot of fun
watch watching LCS and worlds with new
champions and you know it just gets all
crazy you see a bunch of new champions
here Darius the GP running around my
just killing everyone but like from an
owner perspective and a player
perspective it's honestly really
discouraging in order to make like an
uneasy an example I would probably say
it's like if you look at like the NBA
right where they go into like the NBA
Playoffs it would be essentially
changing like the basketball basketballs
wait and changing in Telex shooting a
bowling ball instead of a basketball and
a lot of my players practice like 10 to
12 hours a day
and you know it's all fun practice
either because I wake up at like 10:00
they do vaud review dependent wall and
then they scrim from 12 to like 9 p.m.
and they play silly cue they're pretty
much really invested into this rate and
all their hard work essentially goes
away but Reggie wanted stepped further
he pointed out to the constant
mentorship to make it really difficult
for a non endemic investor to feel a
team particularly because they don't
really understand the game from like a
lower organization's endpoint like a lot
of investors are buying into the buying
into eSports because they don't
understand how didn't have a get around
and they don't understand what to do
it's a lot harder for them so they're
losing millions of dollars by putting
money into something that they don't
understand and that's what any
investment right if you like if you
don't understand a space and you put
money into it then you're just basically
taking a gamble and if the game is
constantly changing with relegation as
the punishment for getting the meta
wrong that Gamble is just too risky
needless to say riot didn't love getting
called out like this by one of their
more prominent team owners C team
solomid is the most popular team in
North America and if Reggie was really
known Ryan
TSM fans were likely to follow but Ryan
didn't respond with a carefully worded
press release in fact they probably
wouldn't have said anything and handled
everything behind closed doors
however riot co-founder mark Tryndamere
merrill seemed to take Reggie's comments
personally in the original comment he
posted to the League of Legends reddit
Meryl wrote love me some Reggie but if
he's so concerned about the financial
health of his players maybe he should
spend some more of the millions he has
made slash makes from league of legends
on paying them instead of investing in
other eSports where he is losing money
marijuana's thought to criticize more of
Reggie's comments including saying that
team owners did have the means to pay
players better they were just holding
out on them and that patches were being
designed to make the viewing experience
more exciting not to balance the game
better for pro player as you might
expect that didn't go over great even
though Merrill edited his post to tone
down the language his glib seemingly
uninformed and mostly unpopular comments
spread across the League of Legends
community like mimetic why
finer and Reggie was quick to respond
the day after Merrill's reddit comments
he released a twit longer in which he
pretty thoroughly rebuked most of
Merrill's points in particular he had
this rather scathing response to
Merrill's assert Asian that Reggie
shouldn't be spending the money he makes
on League of Legends into other games
most LCS teams lose money because
stipends are stagnant sponsorships for
LCS operations are shrinking and the
cost of player salaries content
production support staff and housing
costs are spiraling up Reggie pointed
out that sponsorship activation
opportunities were scarce and that Riot
steam stipends didn't even come close to
covering the cost of operations for an
LCS team and while teams had fewer ways
to make money than ever player salaries
were naturally going up as great players
realized they could ask for more money
from teams that wanted to win and again
outside investors just weren't
interested in a system that could see
them lose everything to just one bad
split
shrim Damir came back with a twit longer
of his own effectively walking back a
lot of his claims and agreeing with most
of Reggie's points but the damage was
done public opinion had been pulled out
from under riot and the time was right
to instigate change
Reginald made one more twit longer post
on August 24th telling maro that a
proposal from several na LCS team owners
and players would be in his inbox that
day and then the post with a hashtag LCS
forever
LCS forever spread quickly - with
several na LCS team owners banding
together under its banner and it seemed
like for the first time in a while
they were going to the negotiation table
with some form of leverage over riot but
fans wouldn't get to find out exactly
what that meant for a while it took
until November for firm reporting to
come out about rice negotiations with
teams when slingshot esports published a
letter from teams to riot detailing some
of their demands among other things the
documents outline some of the team
owners proposals and responses to riots
proposals and by April 2017 we have to
score eSports we're reporting that riot
was getting ready to franchise for the
2018 season finally in June
ten months after Reggie's initial
interview with SCARA right and that was
franchising was coming to the NA LCS
with no relegation permanent sponsor
teams and revenue sharing and we think
this is great because for teams this
will enable them to make better
investments and more investments into
their squad and it should in theory help
with competitive parity because you give
revenues up and down the table and for
pros we think this is a big change
because it gives them upside and benefit
from the growth of the league in the end
Reggie's comments very directly led to
Wright implementing a franchise system
that has only been healthy for the scene
and has helped all of eSports - we saw
franchising being discussed as a serious
option for even more games leagues and
more non endemics putting their money
into the scene unfortunately it wasn't
all roses and sunshine you got kind of
screwed while na flourished under
franchising in fact Europe isn't getting
franchising until 2019
after split after split of declining
viewership revenue and players leaving
for na but franchising did happen and
was thanks in part to us where do you
get off totally us you guys definitely
not that riot was probably considering
franchising beforehand and that they
only acted after a concerted effort from
team owners and pressure from fans in
order to make the scene better and even
then only after nearly a year of
negotiations
it was definitely us mission
accomplished you're welcome thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button